歡迎收看
題材大人秀最受歡迎的教學
單元 標古在線等
說來也巧
上一集的標古在線等
那時候說實話
很多很多標古
都是突破盤整區間
往上就一大波有沒有
今年很多的題材
神技類 軍攻類 儲能類
AI類 輪來輪去
可是最近好像盤面的畫風有點改變了
發現怎麼突破了就下來
或是下去了又上去
你空也不是多也不是
因為盤整突破也還是有分喔
上次教真突破
今天告訴你
有的是假突破
好 每次你都說啊
就技術現行很簡單
就是一張圖
把圖當神一樣就好了
可是還有真突破跟假突破
對 當然有
對啊 那這樣不是很複雜
我們在上漲也有增上漲 假上漲
回後買上漲
我怎麼知道
對 回後買上漲
也告訴你不是100%
所以你是不是紅K做停損
對嘛 如果你買了他不漲
那往下跌你就趕快跑
那盤整突破也是我們
多頭進場的一個位置
我們有兩個嘛
一個回後買上漲
一個盤整突破
上級我們叫盤整突破
那我們其實上級也講了
你盤整突破
還是要先守好停損
那如果一直往上漲
就跟停水沒關了
你就要做好停力
這兩樣都要做好
如果你在這幾天
或上禮拜你買了盤枕突破大漲
可是如果大盤不好
你又沒停力
它還是一樣會跌回來
它還是一樣會跌一個三天 五天
對不對
所以這兩個事情
一定要按照紀律去做
好 那我們今天來講假突破
假突破就是突破
沒有突破了 然後又失敗了
這個就叫假的
那我們假突破其實有分兩種
大家可能平常沒有去注意它
那分哪兩種 一種是多頭的高檔
多頭已經走了兩三坡 盤枕突破
你當然還會進去做
因為有的多頭會一直漲 對不對
那另外還有一種是空頭的低檔
空頭低檔的突破 那個盤枕突破
就是打底完成 就變多頭了
對不對 我們很希望空頭後來底底高
變頭頭高嘛
那應該就是多頭啦
可是他如果也失敗的話
就是這個地方打底就失敗了
所以在這個任何地方的盤整突破
都請你注意
只不過你要稍微看一下
他前面是多還是前面是空
是
這個盤整的前面
所以他有兩種
因此我們要去注意一下
他是真突破還是假突破
一個是多頭高檔假突破的反轉
那就是假突破後來變成真下跌了
那就變空頭了
其實這個在我們的股票市場
大家也經常聽到一句話
這個叫穿頭破底
對不對 往上穿頭
結果又把盤枕跌破了
假穿頭真破底了
所以這個當然就整個就反轉
就變空頭一直走
那這個是空頭盤枕
然後穿頭又破底
那空頭就繼續跌
就是沒有多頭反轉 沒有成功
那這個大部分都是
底部這樣子的發生
各位也會講
說這不是已經股價很低了嗎
那為什麼盤整還會失敗
還會假的
大部分都是季線壓住了
因為你在打底的時候只有上月線
然後你一突破那個季線
如果是一般來說角度很陡的話
那個壓力就很大
那你這個地方後續買盤
如果力量不夠
有可能就被他再打下來
是
那個趨勢又繼續走空
所以這兩個請大家
去做一個區別
做一個區別
好 那我們來看一下
一般來說假突破
有些什麼樣的特性
讓我們可以觀察
我們可以知道
糟糕了 我碰到假的了
對不對 就好像我們現在
很多詐騙集團
好討厭喔
你碰到詐騙 你要趕快動作
趕快閃人了
你不能說
記了一次 又記兩次
還繼續會
那你這個沒有做動作
好 那我們來看一下
這前面是一個多頭
那現在進到盤整
我們一般很高興盤整突破了
那這時候你要注意一下
第一個這個盤整的位置是不是太高了
比如說你這個100塊
現在已經到200 300塊的盤整
那這個時候突破
當然你的價位就更高
那你當然就要稍微的注意一下
那我們怎麼注意呢
還是在我們的技術面上
它會反應給你看
大部分的假突破都會呈現這樣
第二天會有一個長黑
昨天長紅嘛
那第二天就出現一個長黑
而且這長黑都有帶量
下面都會兩天都帶量
紅K要突破盤整
一定會有大量
不然它就沒辦法突破
可是突破完了第二天又出現大量
但是是黑的
大概這你又講80%就是假的了
大概是假的
如果你的黑K又把紅K的1.2點破了
昨天比如說紅K漲到8%
你今天又跌下去 跌掉一半
那這個80%都假的
你大概要做好一些心理準備了
那再來
如果這個黑K的量比紅K的量還要大
那90%都是假的了
這個機率已經非常高了
那我們做好了這個準備怎麼辦呢
那當然就是我們講
買進去就是一個停損
你如果再下去我叫停損
停損完了還要觀察
因為你停損完不是馬上就破底
它還在盤整區
但就等
如果它真的盤整跌破
我們這個叫真下跌
那時候你叫做空
如果想賺錢就做空
要不就不理它了
一個叫賺錢
一個就是因為你有一個停損
所以你做空要把停損賺回來
對
而且很快就會賺回來
積極的做法
如果我們懂了很多的圖
有的時候停損也就不會那麼在乎了
因為很多人就捨不得賣
哇 我又賠5% 賠6%
你捨不得停損
但是如果你知道這個技術面的道理
你就賣了
然後很快你又可以賺回來
不一定不要被套牢
然後兩三個月還賺不回來
這是我們很重要一個觀念
我今天有看到一張對賬單
他買到一檔股票 先上衝 他買多
可是後來下洗他發現不對
立刻反手作空
所以當天還是獲利的
但就是有那樣的
就是像朱老師講的
如果今天停損了
明明看到趨勢往下
事實上坐點空把他轉回來
是比較積極一點的作法
就是你還要再確認
他真的下去了
不然你會被兩頭疤
你今天停損 結果你又作功
作功他又上來了
所以我們在做技術面
就是有圖為評
這個圖確認了
那我就可以反手做
我們看一下前面幾個例子
都一樣這個是多頭進到盤子
真的有一個大量紅黑突破
好高興對不對
所以你看這根紅黑還跳空
所以很強
那下面是有放大量的
那我有跟大家講
這個爆大量
就是比昨天的量大出兩倍以上
只要超過兩倍以上
這個都叫爆大量
跟昨天來比
那很高興
可是第二天你有沒有發現
這個黑黑的量
比紅K還要大
而且紅K的二分之一也跌破了
大概百分之九十都會
所以你看再來如果它還是跌
當然你就停損
因為它把紅K跌破了
那停損你不能馬上空
你看一天兩天 三天 四天
都沒有往下跌
你要確認它對不對
你確認它跌破了
它就下來了
所以你這一根在這一段
你大概就可以板回來了
也就是說你是一個小培
然後你有好的機會
就趕快給他賺回來
這是一個多頭的高檔
它是一個假的跌破
所以我們多看幾張圖
或者我經常跟觀眾
或者同學講
我們教學時間有限
只能夠講個兩張圖 三張
那你回去再找
你再去看有沒有現在的圖
以前的圖都是這樣
紅的配黑的兩根大量
你去找
找多了你下次就知道趕快跑
因為九成都要疊了
你不一定要停損
對不對
你不一定要等到明年停損
我今天就先跑
所以我這個是跟大家講
經驗值很重要
是
因為你碰到很多次
所以這個經驗非常重要
那我們看一下是不是一模一樣
這是股票很活潑的
你看是不是一模一樣
對耶
這個黑天的量
比紅色的量還要大
大兩倍
而且當天你就要賣
因為它當天就把紅黑疊潑
而且一個好長的上限
這個叫長黑吞噬
所以你看他一定是往下的
那你往下 然後後面就做空
就不要再做多了
這個到底其實很簡單
我常常講一個大盤
尤其我們最近大盤都很弱
很多股票大家都來不及賣
那不是來不及
是在高檔有訊號的時候
你就沒有做好準備
如果你做好準備
你就會第二天就賣掉
那你就看著他一直跌
那只有後來的問題就是怎麼辦
就在問怎麼辦
但是朱老師這個是不是一樣是收盤前確認
對 收盤大概是要收盤
因為其實你盤中觀察 心中也有數了
因為你盤中就看他一直放量
然後開高就一直殺
我看他一直放量
我要不要先解決他
不要再等到收盤前十分鐘
那個又叫做經驗值
因為他就不是一個百分之百的一個紀律
他沒有辦法做成紀律
他只能夠說讓你在盤中去觀察
它的確今天是很弱
開高走低放大量
也就是說大概百分之八九十
今天都要下去
那你就可以提早走
好 經驗值
對 經驗值
以後真的要講這個
就要用另外一個方法
能夠提早走
你可以用另外一個方法
其實我們在前面教學有講
只是照他說
不適合講盤中的當沖
這個是盤中的當沖去走的
你這樣講他們會罵我
對 因為盤中當沖你就知道
放量一直殺一直殺
盤中是空頭
我們可以講
來一起來教我們有問題
但我警語會上很足
因為我們之前有講過幾當沖
就有好多人來罵你知道嗎
我們是認真在教學
沒錯 沒錯
可是看的人心也要知道
技術分析不是只有這麼一點
它的範圍很廣
它有很多綜合考量
對 你還要很多經驗值
所以我說這有很多叫經驗值
你慢慢培養 你就可以培養出來了
還有詐騙很喜歡我們講當初那一集
把我們的片段都倒板去用
而且大家也要理性的去思考
一個當初是很難的操作
怎麼可能說二三十分鐘就可以把它講完
或是就學起來
對 你只能夠學到其中的一部分
而且我們那時候只講個開盤而已
後面盤中怎麼變的話
你都不知道
所以你不可能這樣就去操作
那我們剛剛講的前面是多頭
那現在叫空頭了
空頭也會進到盤子
那我們叫打底對不對
它不疊了嘛 叫打底
那打底了 爆炸突破
好高興轉多了
一般來說
如果你打底時間稍微久一點
大概三個底的話
月線大概就做好了
就可以上月線
那上了月線以後
如果你要去做多的話
就千萬記得上面還會有其他的軍線
還有季線
或當然如果是假突破
第二天你就會看到同樣的情形
看到大量長黑疊下來
那你就知道這個疊有可能要失敗了
所以你當然按照紀律也是一樣
到時候疊破你就停損
然後反過來再把盤整疊破
你就開始繼續做空
這個就是打底失敗
我們的觀察重點
第一個有沒有爆出天亮
一樣爆天亮才會往上攻
結果第二天又爆亮沙
第二個要嚴守停水
跌破進場的K線
我們就趕快出場
第三個
第二天如果大量黑K繼續下跌
又把長紅K的低點跌破
第一個我們先停水
停水以後再觀察
他把盤子又跌破
表示這個底部就沒有了
就失敗了
所以這個不能當頭
因為這是在下面
所以這個叫底部打底失敗
那我們怎麼辦呢
我們就可以繼續做空
很多長線的空頭都會走這樣
因為它跌了
比如說200塊跌到100了
它可能就會打底了
打底出
它有很多原因
一個是你剛好轉多的時候
大盤變弱了
那做的人想說不要做了
他又下去了
所以這你的原因很多
但是我們就看土就可以
那土會表現
哎呀 不好了
所以你就趕快走
走了以後你再繼續做空
好 因為你知道打底往下突破
大家戒心反而會不像高檔反轉那麼快
我想說哎呀 他說打底那麼久了
他說那麼便宜了
對 還會想要再拖一下
好 那我就再重複我
我教課的幾句名言
股價沒有高低
沒有所謂的高股價低股價
高還會更高 低也可能更低
只有多空
如果它是空就還會再低
如果它是多
即使你在高擋突破它還會漲
因為它還是多頭嘛
它還會漲
所以這一點當然
還是要一些做久的心裡面
才能夠接受
在正常人它很難接受
你看有四位數股價跌到剩兩位數
對啊
有兩位數股價漲到四位數的
所以如果你漲多了
你又不敢買 疊了你又不敢空
所以這個就說
如果你把剛才我講的話
去記得大概就可以做了
而且為什麼我講
你說愛股價那麼高可以做嗎
那也還是一樣
如果你做不到
做不到按照技術面你就走
沒有告訴你做不到我就要一直爆
對不對
那很簡單
我們看這張圖就知道
這邊就是空頭
這個空頭上面是不是有
打亮被跌破了
那表示你這個你做多是做不到
你不要做了
有可能紅可以買
我要突破盤整區了
那你就趕快離開
空頭確認了
那我就來做空
你就可以做到一段
因為這個地方沒有假突破
它就是一個頭頭低跌破前低
所以它不是假突破
那跌到這麼深
居然不跌了
你看底底高
滴滴高飛變多了
在一般人說
那現在我又可以做多了
對不對
可是你看第二天
有沒有更大量的黑K
這個黑K量比昨天還要大
我們剛剛去講了
這個九成都是假的
所以你大概心裡知道糟糕了
好 那這個
這個黑K疊破紅K
所以這叫停水
停水點
停水完了
我們的底部在這
對不對 低點在這
跌破了 它就繼續走空
這個叫增下跌
我們就繼續做空
所以你不要去管後面是跌多少
你看這一段就跌很多
你看90塊跌到40幾塊
是不是 所以你不要管
反正趨勢它是空
它就會一直走空
如果你從上面看150 160了
那你不會會覺得
這邊都破100了 你就不敢空
那實際你破了100現在變成44級
100到44級機會跌掉一半
所以第一個就是說
你如果有多單一定要走
要不然你就100跌到50
你就賠了50%對不對
第二個我走了以後
那我可以去做空
你還是賺錢
你一樣還是賺到50成
所以多空基本上
如果我們用技術分析
都不會有太大的問題
那我們現在只是在技術面上
去看這一些很明顯的訊號
這個假突破的訊號很明顯
我們怎麼看它就是這樣發生
也就是說你只要相信它
你如果看到這樣你就相信它
這個是假突破
那這樣你碰到假突破
就不會有什麼問題
我就知道啊我碰到
因為在股票市長我們常常講
變化的因素非常多
也不是只有說這個基本面
或什麼都有可能
國際盤一個利空
馬上全部都受影響
那我們就是要在技術面做應變
這個也是一個空頭
然後再疊 進到盤子
這邊上越線 上越線
而且又過前高
這邊變多頭了
變多頭了
然後看沒有紅K放大量
第二天沒有長黑
所以這個量也沒這麼大
那是你要注意 它已經不漲了
那把紅K跌破 這叫停損
你已經跌破紅K了嘛 就停損
那停損的第二天
把盤整的下景線跌破 就開始走空了
所以我們從這邊
這些範例各位都知道
我們沒有辦法說一支股票
一定要漲到哪裡
一定要跌到哪裡
我們永遠都跟著你的圖的變化
做我們的動作
我們去做應對的動作
而且我們剛剛講的這麼多股票
也有好股票 也有壞股票
對不對 也有基本面好的
也有基本面不好的
可能比較投機的
對 但是它的走法
我們在技術面的看到這個
都要做一些
我一常講技術面的操作
就是一個紀律的操作
你可以把這個寫成紀律
我如果突破買了
那第二天如果這樣
那我就要做什麼
對不對 這就你的紀律
你每次碰到我們都這樣做
那我剛剛有講
你按照這樣做
基本上你不會賠錢
因為你後面是賺的
你後面是賺的
希望大家能夠
我一邊講圖
一邊也希望能夠體會操作的
一些領悟
如果你領悟了
你就願意去這樣做
而且你也不會擔心受怕
好 所以主老師常教我們一件事情
就是紀律跟機率
技術現行是一個大數據統計之後
這樣發展的機率是很高的
但不代表100%
那你相信這樣的機率
竟然剛好你就做到機率
就是圖形發生這樣的變化
我們馬上動作
當然有可能小小的可能性
後來它不是照著這個機率走
可是絕大多數相信
會是累積贏家一個
很必要的過程
那接下來
朱老師還是很佛心的
要在榮耀班裡面
幫大家找一下
最近的圖有沒有人有這種假突破的現象
或者是他有可能即將突破
但是我們可以來判斷一下
會不會假突破
朱老師來幫我們篩選囉
大批集團不要來
不要來 不要來
這個是理財當然就專屬的榮耀班